[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a year ago
george floyd was killed on camera
his death led to mass protest in the us
but it also inspired a movement here in
the uk
[Music]
people demanding change
this is stuart lawrence he wants to find
out why you murder four
000 miles away at the hands of u.s
police
meant so much to so many in this country
i was at home on the sofa with my wife
my son the video came on
no warning or nothing beforehand
my son was then saying why is the
policeman kneeling on the man's neck for
it made me feel sick it made me feel
sick
this is personal for stewart in 1993 his
older brother
was murdered by a racist gang his name
was stephen lawrence
in the weeks after tens of thousands
took to the streets of east london
there's a lot of anger around because
again it was another murder
it just felt like they weren't
interested in doing anything
[Applause]
there's a lot of frustration and anger
from a lot of young people at the time
among the crowd was one of stephen's
best friends
when steven died i think everyone was
just just had enough
it was just an element of fear um
injustice
and almost um i would say you we wanted
to fight back
it's starting off quite peaceful i
understand because i wasn't there i was
16 at the time
so definitely won't let me out on that
one
[Applause]
there was a moment when the police
pinned everybody in and then bottles
started flying the police started
smashing people
it was scary
[Applause]
the 93 march i think it paved the way
to where we are today in some respects
because it made national news
but most of it was down to your parents
stu you know
they never gave up
stephen lawrence's killing became one of
the country's highest profile
unsolved murders
i was very angry because it just said we
told them who it was
lots of people trying to tell them who
it was and it just they weren't doing
anything
there was one mp in particular that
helped the lawrence family
stuart wants to meet her for the first
time
we took your mother to see jack straw
who was the shadow home sector at that
time as a touring government
your mother just blew him away she just
completely blew him away
he went into the meeting with doreen
skeptical having been told by the
metropolitan police not getting too
involved
and he came out having promised her
an inquiry i mean the extraordinary
thing
about the mcpherson inquiry was
macpherson
was the first kind of establishment
figure
to talk about institutional racism that
really changed
attitudes in the society as a whole
i'm not the first type of person that
goes on protests i'll be honest
so i was quite apprehensive nervous
one year on from the blm protests
stewart has come to meet a well-known
activist
who is there everyone wants to see and
demonstrate and feel that there's been
meaningful change and
things are different and as i said you
can tell by today people don't feel like
things have changed and things like i
don't
so i don't feel like things have changed
i feel like we have progressed in
certain areas
but the biggest issue that i found is
our lack of understanding in regards to
racism
yeah because to this day since what 1999
when mcpherson report came out and
expressed the fact that the police were
institutionally racist in 2021 we are
still debating that conversation
[Music]
brixton soup kitchen feed and cares for
the homeless in the local community
soul stewart this is our kitchen this is
where the magic happens beautiful
so since black life matters and we've
lost george floyd over america how's
that affected you and your local
community
um i feel like it's had a big effect
because it's brought back
emotions from so much other things that
have happened in this country obviously
we're not used to seeing people directly
being killed on camera by police but
you know there's been a lot of brutality
whether it be racist attacks or whether
it be people dying in police stations
and there's no information
so it wasn't just about america it was a
worldly thing
and just seeing people from all
different backgrounds all different
communities getting involved
and getting together to rally and
protest and say look we cannot have this
no more
the government's response to the blm
movement was to commission a report
into race relations it found no evidence
that britain
is institutionally racist
stewart meets a young black frontline
officer
in the met so what is the the attitude
and
and
viewpoints from your friends your point
of view about you uh dining this
beautiful uniform and giving your
service to
our community so i grew up in south
london and nigeria so
it you know it's not on it won't be a
surprise to hear that i've had friends
who have been on the
uh wrong side of the law 100 and you
know i have to
make decisions yeah on what sort of
relations i can have
uh with some with some of these people
sure
naturally you know i have lost uh
friends how's that though come on now
like i mean any friends that you've had
from
childhood as well um yes yeah friends
friends from childhood i've lost friends
but i've gained friends as well sure i
don't know if this is true or not and
i'd like to hear if you if you know this
or not but taking the knee
yes as as is this something that you've
been told that you can't do
are you allowed to do it if you wanted
to i know there was a bit a few little
questions around
a few officers having more the central
london protest yeah in doing that
i'm not doing that because it's hard
question that's a hot question i'm not
like too much
taking the knee um so no no one has
actually told me
uh whether i should or should not take
the knee um would you though would you
take your knee
i'm going to be very honest with you
this is my i'm very ambivalent
yeah uh some days you watch certain
things
you see certain things you're riled up a
little bit and then you go to work the
next day like i'm definitely going to be
taking the them
yeah yeah on other days you're like wait
let me take a step back and try to see
things in a more objective manner
i mean taking the knee is largely a
symbolic
gesture yeah you know does it
necessarily change
our practices in of itself debatable
one of the most iconic moments of the
blm movement was the toppling of a
statue in bristol
the statue of slave trader edward
colston was torn down
by a group of activists
it looked like the city came together it
changes things because people start
talking
but what we've got to be careful of not
to do is mistake
events for systemic change sure all
right processes that i just kicked off
yeah and what we had was a very symbolic
moment
but we also have to be acutely aware
that history
and history in a fight against racism is
full of very symbolic moments
that we're emotionally engaging and
produce nothing yeah
and that has then been a pathway to
increase cynicism and despair yeah
so it's constant constant you have to
take every opportunity
that comes and that was only an
opportunity
bristol has a thriving afro-caribbean
community
right in the heart of it is glenn's
kitchen
what did the toppling of the statue mean
to the people there
well it should make a difference now
because people standing up for what is
right
if it costs some people will be offended
some people feel you know
so it's just one of those things you
know i mean people just have to just
move on
yeah back in the days it was hard
because you go
downtown and you're walking with with a
girl
you know maybe english girl you know you
will get
abused and they want to attack you yeah
it doesn't happen no more yeah
black lives does matter we're in this
world right now we're just gonna be
have to live together we have to live
together man and
put away all those foolishness and just
live in one unity and love you know what
i
mean
i just wanted to see how far we have
come from year on
you know has anything changed as
people's mindsets change
i think the one thing that sticks to my
mind is people
still feel like in certain corners their
voices are not being heard
why did george floyd's murder really
hit home with people in the uk they saw
injustices they happen over here with
the stop and search figures the
definitely
custodies the layers of the the
institutions that discriminate against
you
we've got problems and issues over here
as well
if you were to offer george floyd's
family and he advised what would you say
to them
yeah that again that's that's a hard one
because
everyone's journey through grief is
different especially if it's someone
that's
been ripped away from you without any
call of cause or reason
that's harder to take the only piece of
advice i could give
is that you know there will be a day
where you will
feel like being happy again
you